ah bonjour je suis vraiment très content
de vous voir vous avez remarqué comme je
suis beau et propre
aujourd'hui ouais nous allons passer une
journée formidable surtout à cause de la
surprise que j'ai préparé
ouais je vais vous le dire mais non par
les paraît c'est un concours de chant
ouais voilà le facteur je lui ai
justement demandé de venir pour savoir
s'ils pourront participer au concours
bonjour kazemi un jour martin tu m'as
l'air bien gai aujourd'hui marais et je
suis dans une forme étonnante repos mais
ça fait plaisir à voir ça pour sûr bon
alors dis-moi pourquoi tu m'as fait
venir à je voudrais savoir si vous
pouvez chanter ooh
pour sûr je crois même casimir que j'ai
un assez joli brin de voix pourriez me
faire entendre quelque chose au pour sur
la pelouse
fabien s'est déréglé bien sûr que j'en
connais un autre ou d'air à bon temps
j'ai d'autres grands au factor ça suffit
merci oui ça n'a pas l'air de beaucoup
de plaies car si si si si beaucoup aussi
non mais je voulais juste entendre
quelques secondes
alors si tu n'as plus besoin de moi je
vais continuer ma tournée
c'est ça bien au revoir casimir au
revoir je suis le pense on la la la la
la
bien que je n'aie pas d'oreille il y à
certains jours où elles me font très mal
ah non je ne pouvais vraiment pas le
prendre pour le concours qui n'est pas
là monsieur du snarr bonbons casimir
j'adresse mes salutations distinguées
j'en remercie alors que t'arrive-t-il je
voudrais savoir si vous savez chanter
quelle question je sais bien que les
gens de ma qualité connaît dès leur
naissance
la pratique de tous les arts et quand on
pousse alors ça va tu as plus ben oui
oui oui je vois l'entousiasme torrent
nuit
c'est normal et je dois constater que
cela fait plaisir de voir qu'une belle
voix comme la mienne peut toucher le
coeur de naître si peu raffiné que le
tien
il a la chance que je n'ai rien à faire
sinon je lui montrerai comment un être
aussi peu raffiné que moi quand je lui
montrerai à la boxe a alors bloqué et
demi à 4 ans tous deux mois eh bien
m'a fait venir pour entendre quelques
notes de ma voix ah oui voilà ça y est
je me souviens oui le facteur aimeraient
apprendre à chanter oui et il aimerait
faire un duo avec vos aïeux ou est il ce
brave m il il vient juste de partir
pareil bon je le rattrapais merci
casimir vraiment voilà julie
heureusement salut bonjour julie on tue
vraiment très très belle tu as vu j'ai
mis la robe que tu préférant oui c'est
rabelais je suis très content de
publicité alors quoi
explique moi le mystère pourquoi nous à
te demander de mettre nos plus beaux
habits
oui maintenant j'aimerais d'abord que
françois soit la havane voilà justement
rien
bonjour casimir bon je lis chemises
habillées de remarquer c'est ma plus
belle et je deviens tu as un spa des
gammes n'y a pas un flic et bien casimir
explique moi ce qui se passe
or n'ont jusqu'ici j'ai rencontré
personne on dirait que tous les enfants
ont disparu de l'île
mais c'est vrai regardez le jardin oui
mais alors il n'y a pas un seul enfant
et bien moi ça ne m'étonne pas du tout
c'est une surprise c'est une surprise à
cuisiner qu'est-ce que ça explique
qu'elle est cette surprise encore un
petit instant
bon allez voilà ça y est c'est l'heure
alors vous voyez le grand rideau qui
hélas oui oui je l'avais pas remarqué
eh bien tous les enfants sont assis
devant les attentes
et qu'est ce qu'ils attendent mais le
début du grand concours de chant un
concours de chant et c'est fantastique
mais dis moi quelles vont être les
concurrents et bien il y a julie et
françois thouvenot
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs le
grand concours de chant va commencer le
premier concurrent s'appelle françois
les fascinations d'y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gray savent c'est ce que je voudrais
ainsi livré mon petit ou très grand
j'aimerais le poney
être l'air oublie les souris ont des
vies extraordinaires jeu
[Musique]
vous plaît on explique que ces mystères
je voudrais être très savants que d'être
le secret des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses calquer at-il deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des étoiles il voit
ton parfois des lions d
s'ils gagnent les moins d'eau les
corbeaux et les marches tout heureux
les canaris
là
découvrant les dauphins l'est parce
qu'ils sont de vrais mammifères
son
c'est
rendez vous
la mer je voudrais être très sale en
connaître le secret des choses et y
at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants russe quelqu'un est une
deviner ce coup trouve au delà des
épaules ils voient qu'on parle pas des
lions des hommes des cigales craie
c'est ce que je voudrais c'est
fini
petits et grands
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]